I woke up one day and all the money it
was all like gone I was launching all
these gyms we were filling them up and
he was like dude you're leaving all this
money on the table I was like yeah I'm
leaving all this money on the table I
should be owning all these gyms that I'm
launching he's like dude you launch a
new gym every month I'll staff it up and
run it and we'll just split it 50 50. I
was like cool I don't want to run him so
that was the deal so I launched this gym
we murdered the launch 370 something
people signed up which is really big for
like a gym launch and I was like all
right man like ready to run the thing he
was like oh no I've got my location you
handled that one and I was like whoa no
no this is not my game anymore and then
I woke up one day and all the money it
was all like gone I was like dude with
that he's like I know you've been
skimming I'm just taking my half because
I know you've already taken out the
other half no I haven't so I printed out
the bank statements and I was like hey
let's meet up and he was like oh I don't
want to see that that's when I knew I
had been played the crazy part is like
he'd already been indicted for fraud and
he was like it was a misunderstanding
and I believed him I got the experience
so lesson learned